[Music]
looks pretty good
[Music]
me and jake are going to be camping here
tonight and we're going to try to catch
our own dinner
so i'm going to show you guys a bunch of
survival fishing techniques so we're
going to see if we can't
get something to eat first things first
should we go find some bait jake well
the best bait for the fishing we're
gonna do is earthworms if you want to
find earthworms go to floodplains just
like this you want wet
mucky soil that's a good place to find
worms
just go and
flip over logs and look under leaves
oh there we go
bingo look at these
yeah look at that those are
that was a great one
[Music]
oh there's oh that was a big one hiding
look at this we found the mother lode
we need to find something to put these
worms in
all right
you want to go find some more worms
oh there's one right there
oh big right inside the lock
that's a good sign you saw where oh yeah
there's oh there's a whole bunch right
there
i got the one
one got a one
oh here put them in there oh
good job jay that is a great one
you got one
got one oh there's a big one
oh come on out
come on out oh yes
nice one
that's a pretty good pile of worms right
there we got probably 18 worms well we
got our bait sorted now i'm gonna make
some fish hooks i'm going to make some
fish gorges which is a primitive fish
hook that you can make with a pocket
knife you can use almost any type of
wood to make a fish gorge but i like
cane or bamboo or really hard woods
and let's see if we can find some in a
ha
right here
okay got an old nasty piece a bamboo or
a cane
i like using bamboo or cane because it's
pretty hard stuff
and it also it it breaks into these nice
little strips
okay just like that
right it's nice and easy to work with
take a little piece like that
not a job for people with fat fingers
okay got a little piece like that
it's just kind of like a little teeny
tiny toothpick with a notch in the
middle
to tie your string now i'm gonna
mispronounce this fish gouge like a
billion times in this video but it's
called a fish gorge we're gonna go see
if we can catch some bluegill with this
and i'm probably going to break or lose
a few so i'm going to hold on to this
little piece of cane keep that with me
all right next we're looking for a
fishing pole and i'm looking for
something that's as long as possible and
ideally green and flexible
just walking back to camp here and i
seeing something roll out there
we might have some decent fish
all right
now if you only have a little bit of
line you can tie it straight to the end
but the best practice is to tie
the fishing line to the handle and wrap
it up to the tip
if you want enough line that it gets
down to about
the handle
there you go just use a little slip knot
to tie the fish gorge right in the
middle next we're going to need a fish
stringer here
there we go got a fish stringer
and i've got a cutting board for my bait
now the most important part about
fishing whether you're using modern
techniques or primitive techniques it's
picking the right location doesn't
matter how good you are if you're
fishing the spot that doesn't have fish
you're not going to catch anything the
fish are also really affected by the
seasons here in virginia in the
wintertime the fish tend to go deeper
and so catching fish with primitive
techniques from shore it gets really
tricky but here in the summer it's not
so bad and in the daytime most of the
bluegill and panfish you're going to
find they're in the shadows along the
shore underneath trees you go find weed
lines or the shadows of a tree that's
where you're gonna find the most fish so
right here we've got a big tree leaning
out over the water i can walk out on
that tree get a little bit more reach
and you got this big shadow here of the
tree is casting on the water and that's
where we're going to fish i'm going to
take the worm i'm going to cut them up
into little pieces about the length of
my fishing gorge because we're going to
shove the fishing gorge
inside the worm like that until it comes
out the other side just got this little
bit of worm with the fish gorge tucked
inside
and you want it so the two wooden spikes
on either end of the gorge just barely
sticking out so what you do is you grab
both sides
of the fish gorge then put a little
tension
like that
you got it perfect the key is the fish
has to swallow it what happens is it
goes down into the fish's throat and
into a stomach and then when you put
tension on it the fish gorge
goes and pops out sideways and jams in
the fish's throat fish gorges are not as
effective as modern fish hooks so you're
gonna get bites and lose the fish about
six times before you land a fish you're
going to lose a lot of bait doing this
it takes a lot more time
i want a little bit better action so
let's go find something else
there we go it ain't big
but there's one
once these guys get hooked it's really
tricky to get them unhooked
oh there we go
just put a little tension on the line
shove a stick down on his throat until
you hit the gouge and then kind of pop
it up and down up and down up and down
until the gouge comes out
tiny little guy let's see if we can do
better than that
there we go first fish on the stringer
okay let's try another spot jacob
a little bit bigger one that's nice
there we go
found a good spot
i got this guy out of the water and he
popped off the gorge
i might have to make a slightly bigger
gorge because the size of the gorge has
to fit the fish
you notice that all these fish are cut
about the same size it's the perfect
size for that type of gorge you want a
bigger fish sometimes you need a little
bit bigger gorge i think my gouge is
just a hair too small and it's getting
beat up pretty good so i'm going to make
another one real quick if you want to
make these gouges as delicate as
possible otherwise they won't sink when
you put the worm on them all right
there's the new gouge it's about maybe
30 percent longer than the other one but
about the same weight so we'll see how
that does things kind of cool down we're
going to try another spot here
oh this might be useful later on
yeah i'll take this too
well there we go gouge isn't too big
still catch the little ones
now check it out this one the gorge went
through his nose that's a first all
right there we go
yeah i've gotten better at baiting the
hook
and now i'm getting a fish like every
fourth strike
oh another pool
hey jay look at that
that's a nice one it's another pool
there you go on the fish pile
all right we got enough right don't you
think
yeah
well managed to turn a handful of worms
into about a pound of bluegill
took a couple hours but uh we're gonna
see if we can't turn this into even a
better dinner
[Music]
i think they're all dead
now while i have to catch my dinner
tonight
uh jacob does not i brought plenty of
snacks and food for him which he has
been enjoying thoroughly it's one of the
main reasons they come out with me
camping
what we got going on over here looks
like we got a guest
hello dad
hi tom you done with school i just got
off the bus and i ran home
come on over we got plenty of dinner oh
we're eating that
yeah yeah you're cooking that up
we might have some other things for you
too
good take it out though we tried all of
these with the fish gorge you want to
try it yeah that looks awesome hey we're
here
here's the fishing rod
good luck tom
you want to go fishing with him
all right tommy was really bummed that
he had to go to school instead of
joining us so as soon as he got home
from school he rushed himself over here
got these 10 little bluegill cleaned up
and we're going to take all of this
and turn it into more food
all right guys these two bottles we
picked up
i'll put these to use
all right there we go
all right
there you go
with this other bottle to use
brought a little packet of circle hooks
here you want to use circle hooks
because you don't need to set the hook
with circle hooks so these are really
good if you're just going to
throw a line out there and forget about
it
you can try to use a fish gouge to catch
a catfish
but so far i have been unsuccessful in
doing that i have
tried many times
and had many catfish bite
and i've yet to have one hooked and
played
they just don't respond the same way to
gouges now
different species of catfish might do
better like bowl heads might work better
for a gouge there you go got a little
circle hook right there
i like using bluegill heads because
they're tough and they're hard to steal
off the hook
so we're gonna
put this one up like that
it's got some nice weight to it
we're gonna chuck this thing
yeah that's not a bad cast at
all so i got this line cast out there
and wrapped around this tree limb so if
anything comes this tree limbs are going
to start shaking and i can see it from
over by my camp plus having attached to
a limb will allow it to give a little
bit so the fish is less likely to break
the line less likely well catfishing is
best in the evening and the sun's about
to set so uh this is this is a good time
we're just gonna let that soak and i'm
gonna get the fire going and we're gonna
start cooking up these bluegill
oh look at this
we got a second visitor
hi nathan
awesome and is your brother carrying
your backpack for you yes that's pretty
awesome brother right there that's super
big brother stuff
oh look catfish hey nathan catfish come
here
[Applause]
look at that saw that i saw that limb
jerking all the way over there
yeah you want it yeah you want to help
huh
yeah i do it yeah yeah okay now you
gotta you gotta be gentle with it and
you gotta guide it
around those snacks see ya
dang it it's already in a snack
okay let's let it sit for a little bit
and see if it gets out it's not a little
snit it's out there snagged like see
where the bubbles are coming up
see the bubbles are coming up
that's where it's at oh i got them out
see we got them in a clear spot now get
them in quick quick don't let them get
around in that grass i'll pull them this
way pull them this way
look at this
look i caught that thing
look at that tom
oh that's a nice fish i got of it
there we go
yeah we're gonna eat them
most important part about fishing is
putting your rig in front of fish and in
most situations you can't do that unless
you can cast
works like a charm
there you go guys
that's a nice channel catfish
it took what eight minutes
once you get dialed in it's pretty easy
all right
oh i hear somebody i think we got more
visitors hi becca oh i'm glad that's you
are you hungry i got your dinner wow
that's decent wow
first we need to get the fire up though
some cedar bark
guys don't roughhouse in
[Music]
there right
need to get some water here
[Music]
okay we got food for mama a couple
mountain houses and some uh yakisoba
and food for you
okay guys i'm gonna start cooking up
fish
[Music]
and then you ate it
well there we go guys two lovely catfish
fillets
mom you're happy with your dinner it's
delicious
jacob do you want some lasagna
[Music]
okay
[Music]
tommy you want one
[Music]
there we go
getting the bones out of these guys
pretty easy once they're cooked just
grab the fins
the spines come out like that
splay it open
and take the spine out i have a little
few straggler ribs two perfect chunks of
meat
let's try some of this catfish
nice and firm i like that
just some peanut oil and redfish
seasoning it's really good
but i understand
you like that sour apple marshmallow
this is over my face looks good i like
the chocolate you take it off becca yeah
i'm gonna put little boys to bed i love
you i'm gonna miss you babe i'm gonna
miss you have fun with tommy thank you
wait can you take the leftovers home
sure
oh nathan nathan you going back mama i
don't blame him the allure of mother is
strong
i love you tommy have fun with you
all right guys we'll see you in the
morning well we finished dinner and mom
nate and jake have headed back i think
it's time for uh me and tom to kind of
button down the camp put out the fire
and uh
just get ready for bed you ready yes
father and son time
pottery sun time yay there's a new star
wars movie on disney plus and i promise
that we get to watch it together tonight
you excited yes yeah yeah yeah
all right guys it's late i'm turning
this off and i'm gonna see you guys in
the morning
we got some cool cooking we're gonna do
in the morning i'll see you then
well it's about seven o'clock we're up
at it and we've picked up where we left
off in regards to star wars shows
rained a little bit last night and we
forgot to put our shoes away
oh
yeah not too bad well for for breakfast
we're gonna have something kind of like
campfire scones i just got some bread
flour and a little bit of yeast in here
we're gonna add some water
i think we had a little mouse
bite the bag last night
i promised becca i'd get back home early
and i need about an hour to make this
bread and yeast do its little thing so
we're gonna break down camp head back
and uh when we hit the one hour mark
we're gonna stop make breakfast
found a random nathan sock
all
yeah
what do you think tom kind of a pretty
spot to take a break and make some
breakfast but don't you think yes all
right let's do it
here start with the little teeny stuff
first
and then if he does and if
yeah
oh that's looking good
tommy are you ready to have your mind
blown
up
tom would you like the first bite of
this
oh
it tastes like a donut
that does taste like a doughnut
mmm that's cool you like that tom
it's so hot it's totally burning my
fingers
you can actually do this without yeast
and it just makes like a thick tortilla
that's also really good but having that
little bit of fluffiness to it
next level what do you think tom best
part of the trip
yeah
just a little ziploc bag of bread flour
one packet of yeast a little bit of
water knead it out into the consistency
you saw cook it in peanut oil done
that's looking good
we got a little bit of extra should we
bring that home to mama
yeah she'd get upset if we found out we
didn't bring it home yeah you hold on to
it
all right tom should we go see mama
let's go see mama well listen guys i
hope you enjoyed this quick little video
learned a little something about
survival fishing techniques
if you guys want to see more videos from
the outdoor boys youtube channel
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every saturday morning if
we survive this hike if we survive this
high if you like this video don't forget
to check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching